[Music]
hey folks I'm Madeleine G and welcome to
another installment of ride with me
every single day we get bombarded with
all sorts of distractions and nonsense
from the White House whether it's
concerning Nordstrom's dropping Ivanka
Trump's brand a 19 second handshake with
the Prime Minister of Japan Trump
posting a fake Abraham Lincoln quote or
being upset over Melissa badass McCarthy
playing Sean Spicer on SNL it seems as
though Trump sits in front of the TV all
day and watches just about anything with
his face on it
and tweets about it his behavior and
temperament not just with his incessant
tweeting but decision-making has raised
numerous questions about his mental
health joining me today to tackle this
very topic is progressive talk and radio
show host David pac-man of the David
Pakman show
hi David and thank you for joining us
it's so great to be with you you have
been covering Trump for quite some time
and we all want to know since recently
Al Franken mentioned that some
Republican members of the Senate are
concerned about his mental health what
do you make of that well my first
reaction was well yeah I mean it's
completely unsurprising in a sense I
mean that the interesting revelation to
me from from what Al Franken said which
initially I think it was on the Bill
Maher show sort of as an aside and then
he was interviewed about it in a sort of
more serious manner on CNN is the idea
that there are lots of Republicans who
are sort of hanging in there with Trump
for now maybe even as long as 2018 so
that they can not impact their
reelection
but that there's this growing movement
that's questioning what on earth is
going on with Donald Trump just
increasing instability a lack of
attention span to the point where now
we've heard that what were one-page
bulleted lists have to be reduced to
single page with mostly maps and
pictures and only a few bullet points if
you want Trump to pay any it's
into it so yeah I mean it's not at all
surprising to me this kind of reminds me
of Charlie Sheen from two and a Half Men
little bit Charlie Sheen s cash tag
winning kind of segue into that which
you touched upon that Trump is known for
having the wild imagination some might
say that of a five-year-old or he's a
bit delusional because he makes stuff up
now Bernie Sanders mentioned that he's a
pathological liar so how much longer do
you believe it's gonna take before we
actually see steps towards hearings on
his impeachment I've talked about this
on my program a lot even if a sort of
rational people you and I could look at
I don't know like the emoluments Clause
of the Constitution and say okay a sort
of reasonable reading of that suggests
that Donald Trump may be in violation of
that aspect of the Constitution because
of his business conflicts of interest
that doesn't automatically trigger
anything it doesn't automatically do
anything and in my personal life a lot
of people keep saying to me Trump did X
how is he getting away with it what's
happening and I have to explain to them
that the law is relevant if there's
somebody there to enforce it and with a
Republican House and Senate it's not
clear that they're ready or willing to
enforce the law and so I think that the
answer to your question really lies in
who that is in power is going to be the
first to take a step along these lines
and I don't know what the answer to that
is what advice do you give people who
kind of wake up in the morning and they
feel like they're going nuts and bananas
over what's happening living in the
twilight zone if you may so what advice
do you have for these people where they
feel as though they're just bombarded
with so much that's coming out of the
White House that some people even feel
paralyzed yeah I mean I'm talking to a
lot of people who just you know every
day they wake up and they start to pay
attention to what news there is and it's
sort of a combination of fear and
anxiety every single day and you know
producing a daily news show it's not
that different for me where I wonder you
know the night before I'll review what
stories am I looking at for the next day
and then I'll wake up and sometimes the
entire show is changed because of
something Donald Trump did at 3:00 4:00
or 5:00 in the morning
my advice is number one you know this
only applies to some of the people that
are watching if you live in a blue state
with a blue legislature relatively
progressive legislature kind of like
where I am in Massachusetts other than
the Republican governor although it's
certainly a sort of decaffeinated
Republican in a sense and Charlie Baker
if you're in a progressive state you are
somewhat protected from the insanity
that is the Donald Trump administration
but that only goes so far even a lot of
state programs depend on federal funding
which Donald Trump could cut etc I think
that for people who are interested in
being activists and hopefully most
progressives are because they see what's
going on I've been on my program talking
about the really specific ways that
individuals can get involved I mean we
have two governor's races in 2017 the
midterms are not that far away the 2020
census is going to be a big part of
fixing gerrymandering which is an
absolute disaster that helps Republicans
win in the House and has for several
elections now so I think focusing on
what can be done and how to get involved
is a good way forward well David it was
a pleasure speaking to you today to
catch David daily check out the link to
his channel below you don't want to miss
it he'll keep you sane folks many of us
are aware that were in uncharted
territory most mornings I roll out of
bed and I think is this really still
happening so I turn on my phone look at
the news and I realize yeah it is so I
go back to bed again so basically my
productivity level is right up here
right now okay look I may be the only
one who's going crazy but I don't think
so I mean what do you guys think do you
think that Trump is in the right mental
state to be President of the United
States let me know comment below well
folks that's it for me
I'm math Angie and you've been watching
ride with me until next time good night
hey guys for more satire and comedy
please hit the subscribe button
you'll be glad you did or not I mean I
can't really guarantee that but what but
I'll just do it it's free I mean why not
right